I didn't even absent our world existed
before I accidentally landed in it I'm
able to tell a story through food which
doesn't necessarily have that aspect in
those cases I'm Liz joy Murray I am a
sugar artist and content creator and
founder of inspired to taste I love
exploring any type of sugar art so
everything from cookies to pies to cakes
macaroons name it I love pies especially
because they almost always feel wistful
you're drawn in by you know the shiny
gooey awesome filling so it's almost
like a through the looking-glass effect
which has rocked out a bit more the
fantasy design and the storybook aspect
and the whole narrative I very very much
enjoy the whole ideation and
brainstorming process and I get super
excited about putting it together one of
the fun things about pies is you have a
set round canvas I always know that I
want to build into that shape and that
frame I was actually looking at I did
illustrations and children's storybooks
trying to come up with curved ideas so I
thought a man in the moon would be so
cool I then make handmade templates
since I don't recreate designs but I
like to start each design with a very
loose blueprint idea once I have the
cookies cut and baked I begin painting
details or blocking out color I try to
make sure everything I use is completely
edible see
and then once I get into that
exploration that's when they get the
little stressful and messy and chaotic I
like to tell people I generally just
make a huge mess until I like the
finished result so it's a lot of hard
knocks and failure and pain from that I
first started making about two and a
half years ago I worked as an art
director for about a decade in Hollywood
and ended up getting really sick and had
to go and leave of absence so I was just
looking for something creative to do and
baking just stood out so I tried it I'm
a person who is all my life I've found
100 miles an hour through the finish
line I've never paused and I have a lot
of nerve damage sometimes I can't feel
my fingertips and so you know I have to
pause and stay calm and try out to freak
out just get there I then gather
mountains of materials and supplies that
I think could make it the best piece
possible and that could be everything
from texture mats to different molds and
then I worked my way to details like
hair or dress volume and folds after I
put the hair on sometimes the makeup
needs to be spiffed ups oh it still
stands out so I'll go back and retouch
then I start adding more and more
details and then more and more details
and more and more details and more and
more life until I feel satisfied with
the amount of stuff on the cookie and
then I just begin building and most of
the pieces are flat one on top of the
other they just cast a really nice
mellow shadow which i think is very cool
I think positioning is very important
sometimes I will figure out the best
positioning and go back in and paint the
pie filling to add details and then
position things on top so that we've got
contrast and pop and depth so it's a
process a lot of times being in the
kitchen and the process is so chaotic
sometimes I don't quite know what the
finished piece is gonna look like and
how I photograph each piece and then
take my time editing I think it allows
me to kind of take it in and be proud of
myself while I'm editing and I do I sit
there and I'm like wow I can't believe
like I I did this like this is so cool
and
just putting it together in the perfect
frame photo and everything it's just a
very fulfilling happy moment for me I'm
creating this little masterpiece in a
moment and I really hope that people eat
them because I have a photograph the
photograph lasts forever and I want them
to fully enjoy the whole process from
viewing the piece of food art to eating
it to sharing it with friends one of the
things I adore about food art is the
ephemeral quality of it it is not meant
to last forever I think one of the
mesmerizing aspects about my work is
kind of a technical aspect I love
playing with deaf texture and different
finishes and I think those things really
draw the eye in and help tell a deeper
story I definitely try to balance style
and substance for pie I do flavors that
coordinate well with the filling I want
it to be a super surprisingly Pleasant
buy as well as a super surprising piece
to look at so for our unicorn hi I
didn't want to use a traditional unicorn
a pastel rainbow color palette I want it
to be a little bit different she started
out just white and I I couldn't do it I
decided that we could add a watercolor
effect to her face which I think gives
it a most splash of mermaid
[Music]
I don't know that I always want to
master something I want to do it well
enough that I feel confident and growing
and continue pushing those materials so
people say I'm a perfectionist I don't
think so I think I'm I think I'm
stubborn and I love learning and that
just that helps me create kind of cool
things it's honest it's 100% me it's me
on a plate me on a cookie it doesn't
feel like my finished piece unless I've
gone above and beyond and it's been
really cool to let loose and just see my
own personal style develop and be able
to define it it's pure enjoyment the
whole process is just it's fun and I do
think that shows my pieces I think my
pieces make people happy every time I
question whether this is my right path
and if I'm doing the right thing another
opportunity comes up that kind of
directs me without me having to think
about it
I have begun expanding the different
pieces of sugar art ideas people ask me
and I try it and I love it and keep
going
this is absolutely been a journey of
self-discovery and not so much
redefining myself but just finding
myself again finding the joy in creating
just for the just for creating just for
being happy and creating something
bright that makes other people happy I
think my identity used to be so tied to
my art director role and to being part
of Hollywood and to being a bit of a
fashion plate that basically getting
knocked on my butt I didn't know how I
would redefine myself and I didn't
really have to is just like finding
myself again and then from there
realizing that it's not the end of the
world to make a mistake and to throw
something out and to burn three pies in
a row I have to redo them like you can't
do it you can fix mistakes you can
continue
to grow and develop starting over at
this point in my life too what's
surprising is something that I didn't
think would go this well or make me this
happy and it's just nice to know I mean
I could probably start over again
sometime and I'll survive
[Music]
you